I'm on a mission today to find the most
bizarre most interesting comic book I
can find San Diego Comic Con used to be
all about the comics it's been around
for decades but now I don't even know
where to look let's go try and find some
books okay it looks like we finally
found some comic books but I'm told that
there are still three halls to go we're
in the 5500 now and we have to make it
all the way to the 1500s to get to the
really old really rare stuff but let's
start now let's look for the strangest
thing we can possibly find now this
seems kind of like a pretty weird comic
will you tell me what's it about well
it's about a boogeyman and he lives in
the hamper and the clasp of the sturdy
socks they have to be dirty and he
really likes pandas so it's got a little
pan the plush besides cake and he does
all kinds of little things he dresses up
in beard hats comes up with funny things
pretends to have a TV show and it's the
three panel comic strip and yeah it's
really easy to get into twenties
remember panda socks boogie man you're
good to go
I'm with Steve a big well comic fest and
he's showing me some pretty interesting
giveaway comics what a giveaway comic
giveaway comics or the comics like when
you're in school and they want to give
you a comic like on electrical awareness
or like perfect example earthquake
awareness for children you know this one
was given away to teach kids not to fly
kites around electrical wires and that's
the Fonz
it's the Fonz for happy days now
everybody knows the romance between
Superman and Lois Lane what's really
interesting is Lois Lane was so popular
at one time that she got her own comic
book
this is Superman's girlfriend Lois Lane
number one and here you have the Witch
of Metropolis Lois Lane on her
broomstick I don't know it's pretty
weird so this is getting weirder and
weirder and now we have the piece de
resistance
Hansie the girl that loved the swastika
superheroes can't always save the day
and when they don't save the day in this
little story Batman
becomes a zombie and so when he can save
the day suddenly becomes Batman but then
when he's helpless he becomes a zombie
well that is probably the most
interesting Batman I've ever seen
Superman is Superman versus Muhammad Ali
did I wrote it and I drew it Superman
when he's under a red Sun loses his
powers so if he's challenged if the
greatest athlete on earth is challenged
is that really Superman or is it the
major boxing champion of the world in
this case if you're under a red Sun
maybe it's Ali as long as you remember
Panda socks boogeyman you're good to go
you